There's a pencil, right?
That's all I need is a pencil.
And a piece of paper
would come in handy.
And I'm about to
write some dialogue,
and it's going to take place
in one place with two chairs,
and that's all I need.
How do you teach
people about drama?
You cannot learn how to write
drama without writing plays,
putting it on in
front of an audience,
and getting humiliated.
[DRAMATIC MUSIC]
Hemingway said,
"Writing is easy--
all you have got to do is
sit down at the typewriter
and bleed."
Throw away all the distractions
and write something.
Every play needs to have
a beginning, a middle,
and an end.
Jean-Luc Godard said, not
necessarily in that order,
and that's why French
movies are so F-ing boring.
[DRAMATIC MUSIC]
The rules to me are
very, very simple.
Your job is to tell a story.
A story has a hero, and
he or she wants one thing.
If it doesn't tend toward
the punchline, take it out.
Gossip is just
creating dialogue.
Billy says to him, "Blah,
blah, blah," and Bob
said, "Bibbity, bobbity, boo."
That's as good a dialogue
as anybody else can write.
[PIANO MUSIC]
I would hope that you
guys would be encouraged
to say, if this class
clown can do so well, hell,
I'll try it too.
I'm not any less
confused than you are.
I just got in the
habit of doing it.
We all have ideas all the time.
Our mind is a raging fire.
At some point you're going to
say, OK, it's going to be bad.
You've got to stand
being bad if you
want to be a writer because
if you don't, you're never
going to write anything good.
We're given a great gift
and a great responsibility,
which is to tell stories
as honestly as we
can and experience things in
the process that are beautiful.
I'm David Mamet, and
this is my Master Class.